oh right it's that time baby
it's that time baby it's me
may I listen to a little something photo
jeez and Mae Mae hey it's Mei Mei Mei is
interesting isn't it because Mae you
know it's really that's when the
calendar kind of starts asking you a
question
may I do this may I bring the summer may
I just reel in a big batch of sunshine
may I make you sweat may miss
interesting huh Mae Mae Mae Mae Mae you
know what that old joke is say what do a
gay Cal say Mae there's something like
that man
today's episode was brought to you by a
gray block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on
the way to the beach in Los Angeles
greibach get that hitter I was in uh I
just got back from the really from the
outdoors I was out there in southern
Utah are so ute being out there and
seeing a lot of different animals they
got small animals and they got large
animals they got alcoholics also they
got it all and did a little camping did
a little yak look hi yakkung not a
cocaine and got into it just I mean it
was like Mother Nature has left her damn
zipper down and I got straight up in
there you feel me it was like mother
nature just I mean I really god I just
really got up in it and that mother
nature
and you get out there in southern
southern Utah or so ute that's what
people call it but you get out there
they got a lot of people you know you
have a yeah you got some people they got
a little bit of a whistle inner in their
talk when they're talking hey hey
whistling you know they got people
really just salt to the earth kind of
you [ __ ] you'll lick a dude's arm and
it'll really taste like salt just that
kind of people you know um you know kind
of song they'll have a man he'll have a
little uh he'll have a treat in his
pocket for an animal and that's natural
you'll see them just break that bastard
out and break out of a you know an
organic tootsie roll or some are a
homemade chocolate for a little badger
for a mountain cat or something it's
that kind of space it's beautiful if
you've never been I just got back and
I'm happy to be here and I'm happy to be
here with you guys let's get in to it
[Music]
try
smell the truck out dog
dancefloor
[Music]
my manager got the try
it's Larry Turner dies
go get drunk outdoor
[Music]
little bit
and it is 2020 2020 and it is the time
it is it and yeah I'm feeling oh I'm
feeling I'm feeling you know I got that
gumption in my Junction bro I'm feeling
that that lift and my gift you know and
I get that when I go in out and in a
nature
I get that recharge you know I get
nature just like just puts a dam just a
like a hose of just just just nature
sauce right into my veins and I just
feel like a little I start feeling a
little more or just part of the earth
you know I feel more like I could just
if I see a rabbit and I wouldn't be
scared or anything even if he was
violent and even if he had a little
knife on him or even if he had a little
cut of uh you know a little sack of um
cocaine or something on his little ass I
would be more you know you're just more
in touch with nature you know a bird
will [ __ ] on you and you'll smile a
little you'll still be pissed but you
you can giggle first you like hot like
all right now I'm pissed but all right
mmm good to be here we're late the
podcast is late we're late did you know
my husband and I were a little worried
about you because your podcast didn't
come on
and we always listen to it in the
morning at any random time I'm a I'm a
registered nurse and been working a lot
with the coded patients well thank you
for uh for working up there you as an RN
and I'm sorry that it's a light but
aren't you glad that is it that at least
it is
gonna be late thank you guys for
thinking about me thanks for calling and
checking I appreciate it somebody else
knew it was late yo how you doing hey
I'm looking for your your podcast it's
not up man I'm not I'm not I'm not
bagging on it
just looking out for hope you well and
chitty-chitty game game and I'm sorry
that it's late you know I was out there
and I was just enjoyment you know I got
enough dual person and single person
kayak I met a man I was jogging and I
met a man over there at uh from a group
called guru Zion because that's where I
went camping and stuff was out near out
east of st. George Utah and that
southern Utah and and it's really they
got a lot of rock out there mystery rock
you'll see a hieroglyphics petroglyphs
and that's basically the old graffiti
that's an as Indian graffiti right there
you know and native just carved
something in there into a rock you know
he might have wrote Oh Rhonda got that
nasty nasty and you'll see that carved
into a rock from a couple hundred years
ago you know oh yeah you know you know
little sidestep has that you know it'll
be a lot of Native American Graffiti
like a little little sidestep has that
uh that pow pow today titty you'll see
you know just just like graffiti you'd
see now but it's from the past and you
can go on different trails and see it
and they got um real weathered looking a
lot of people they've been standing in
the wind out there because it gets real
windy oh if you put your ear up to a
damn kite you'll hear that thing get
erect because this is wind country this
is I mean you'll sometimes you'll see a
sailboat out there just [ __ ] walking
around because that's how much it enjoys
that breeze up
and out and so you and it's um and I you
know it just said you know I got out
there I went and met up with my family
and it was just normal I went to a
restaurant then I went to a restaurant
and had orders I ordered something oh
you got something yeah I got it alright
I'll give you a little money for it okay
well you want to eat it here yeah I'll
eat it here
hell I'll pay you for extra dollars
watch me eat it how is that not an
option at a restaurant for a few extra
dollars they watch you eat it you know
here's 2 X 3 or 6 extra dollars won't
you watch me ingest this for you know
won't you coach me on my eating ok you
chewing too hard with us on the right
side you know don't you chew a little
more on the starboard side you know
balance your bow there you go alright
swallow you know it'd just be nice if
they had that could be an upsell option
at a restaurant or eatery if you're at a
sweet local eatery and somebody says ok
they bought at $19 steak you know they
buy that high-dollar meat cut and then
y'all then you offer that upsell alright
for five extra dollars I'll watch you
eat it
PTL baby there's a lot you know people
would be enjoying uh they would be
buying that that extra experience just
to have that edible chaperone right
there that little chew daddy that little
swallow jockey right there watching you
ride the you know just watching you
experience your food restaurants are
going to start having to do that kind of
stuff because of Corvette they're going
to have to make that extra dollar how do
we pull in that extra side buck okay
here we're gonna offer a unique
experience you know maybe they'll uh
I'll watch you eat for seven
as I'll sit here and my love my love my
little chubby cousin to watch you eat
big deandre or whatever or big quiche or
whatever
look Carrie you know something like that
for nine dollars I'll [ __ ] tickle you
why you eat you telling me you wouldn't
think about that that upgrade option I'm
just telling you we have to start
thinking outside of the box you know you
guys had some calls on how things would
change it with uh with Corbett and what
we could be looking at in the future and
I want to think that all the audio on
the way in that was the North
Mississippi Allstars with their song
drunk outdoors and we'll put the link in
the YouTube where you can purchase that
and also you know subscribe you know if
you feel it I don't like to ask for
things or maybe I do hell I don't know
if I do or don't but if you would like
to do be a subscriber of something this
is something and we'd love for you to
subscribe to the channel I hope
everybody's doing well I want to get
into some things you guys had some some
interesting concepts about how life
would change in the new post Corbett and
here are some here's a couple of
thoughts of you guys had here was a call
gang from Texas
what's up chief what up chief boy and
you notice fella probably huffing on
that bag you don't get the name chief
these days chief used to be a Native
American superior term if you're a
captain of the Native Americans if you
basically this you know the Chris Pratt
a Joey ax if he's a real you know if you
that top dog in the in the feather in in
that in that feather Club then you would
get that name chief but more recently
chief has more of a okay
you know little Gary does a lot of chief
in that hey sucking on that gas brother
puffing that that Gugu that herb maybe
that that weed huffing that nasty nasty
you know he huffing that [ __ ] you know
mr. McGregor's gunpowder dog I'm talking
about marijuana I'm talking about that
puff puff I'm talking about that poor
pop to your brain that dope weed onward
I was watching the podcasters [ __ ]
ladies night one whatever the [ __ ] that
was yeah it was ladies night brother
onward watching that [ __ ] just now you
said what do you thinks gonna go away
and the near future talking about
pooping their attempts taking [ __ ] like
that right we're talking about people
last on last episode we're talking about
people getting their temperatures taken
when you go to an event you know you go
somewhere and now in the future might
they might you know take your
temperature check your for snot they
might you know touch your kids low ass
or something see if it's hot
see if you bring it in a little Timothy
or whatever with that hot ass because
they you can't do it you can't do that
you're not gonna be able to do that as
well you bring in that up temperature
temp temp a--they it's not gonna go over
well with others let's hear more brother
thank you for the call
what's gonna go away I think you know
you're not some tickets like anger you
know but there probably had 10 or 15
makes two restaurants in Louisiana
what's gonna go away though is ships in
queso and chips and salsa sign that [ __ ]
is done homie that's not gonna be on the
menu no more son unless you get it
individually it's not an appetizer no
more you know what I'm saying cuz what
everybody is doing they're getting the
chips bring a chip to the dip putting it
straight in a mouth
go back to the trips going back to the
gift went back straightening mouth damn
you know lean with it rock with it huh
no you can't sanitize every time you
touch a chip you know what I mean them
chips just for me to still see after a
while so so yeah all right Peter all
right be the case so in salsa Gang Gang
Gang bruh
Wow I hadn't thought about that yeah
yeah you're gonna have to each person
will have to bring a couple of their own
chips from home I guess and you know or
yeah
yeah I don't know what they're gonna do
hmm
but yeah you can't have that group you
can't have that that that swimming pool
in the middle of the table you can't
have that little that little cheese
[ __ ] strip mall in the little of the
table and everybody's just scooping in
getting this picking up a pair of ID'd
us or picking up a pair of uh you know
Motorola or something or get some
speakers or some [ __ ] Chinese food
that Chang chopped you know yeah they're
not gonna have that group that little
wah that little um they're not going to
have that little where everybody's just
hands are in they're just that little
bang bang bang up there with the chips
hmm that's gonna be interesting man yeah
that could be one thing that could go
away now you got to bring a couple chips
from home or something you got to write
you know your name on a chip Darren you
know little Ricky and little Ricky got
four chips you know when Darren got nine
chips Darren's big-ass got nine chips an
actor actor over there and you know he
got you know chips running his family so
he got 40 ships come on Hector no you
got 40 chips bro shoot the nine pointer
papa but yeah it's gonna be because
everybody yeah you're not gonna have to
be able to have that that meeting that
meet up in the middle of the table that
could be something could change here's
another thing let's go how things could
change what's up Pete and that's they're
out of central PA and yes central
Pennsylvania if you want to see the
Amish and the Amish are basically like
they're kind of like it's like Halloween
but it's kind of like the most boringest
Halloween you ever been to bruh and you
got to work the whole time dog that's
there anyway they have a lot of Amish in
Central PA gang [ __ ] brother homeward
about an hour south of that [ __ ] mock in
there where they burnt down the junk and
Donna oh yeah up there samokhin were
where they burned down the Dunkin Donuts
Mammoth's [ __ ] damn experiments oh
yeah we used to meet up at the Dunkin
balance yeah I had me a um a head of my
parole officer sometime we'd meet up
over by the Dunkin Donna's brother you
know I used to you know use the can in
there maybe wash out my pants in them
right gang oh so I just wanted to call
and comment about the you know the
change to the handshake you brought up
on last week's podcast and I came up
with something the other day I think it
might catch on I think I like to call it
the et greeting or maybe you just out
stretch that arm take that finger out
and just just barely touch the tip that
way you know you get a little greeting
but you can also maintain that social
distance and I think it also might
change the meaning of giving somebody
the finger so that's what I got man love
you love the podcast keep doing your
date thank you brother I appreciate this
message and that's a yeah could the
handshake we talked about that less we
could the handshake change and what you
would do because it does seem like a lot
to give all 10 fingers out to somebody
in a shake so maybe you do that one
finger just that little that et that
just that little touch me that touch me
tender and you also you would know if
the other person is real wasted or not
because you have to touch their finger
if the line fingers up so if their
finger they can't even hit yours
then you make all this guy's all jacked
up on something do ting you know and
looked at bro I didn't know I remember
one time a buddy of mine and he's a
young homosexual fell actually and he's
certified he's certified he'll tell you
he is and he's really he's been with men
and he knows he's uh you know I'm not
I'm just I'm not telling you I'm not
tattling on anybody's wiener you know
this guy's certified you know prefers
homoeroticism and he I remember the day
he told me that he was uh you know he
really loved men like that like a
specialty and then he really like to hug
men and just you know like he liked to
sometimes put his hands up in another
man's shirt while the man still had the
shirt on and things like that
and um and he said oh I remember when he
told me I didn't know what to do dude he
told me and I didn't know what to do
this probably helped maybe 11 years ago
and I remember taking one of my fingers
but not even joking and just put it into
his mouth off of 23rd Street over there
in Santa Monica by the park and I don't
it was it I don't even know why and he
laughed and I kind of laughed afterwards
but I just didn't know the / certain
interactions you know how to behave
during it someone falls down a stair you
know where someone falls off the back of
a um you know the back of a of a
building of a one-story of a ranch-style
home you know what to do you go you run
over you help you put your hair you put
both arms on them are you okay what's up
you know somebody walks up to you says
hello you know how to do it you shake
their hand you put your hand out they
put their hand out that's a shake that's
a meeting of hands each person brings
one hand to the meeting but they don't
tell you how what
do if somebody comes out of the closet
they don't give you how do you behave
how do you just stick you late that what
do you do with your arms when somebody
comes out of the closet and I didn't
know I just didn't know what to do I
just remember taking one of my fingers
and put it right in his mouth dude and
it was an it was a it was a natural
reaction it wasn't a choice I made it
was a non choice that I did but that's
something that could change people do
something what l now what do you do
maybe take somebody's temperature and
slap them maybe you start smelling them
you smell it back at her pants like a
baby you know I don't know what it's
anything could be you know things are
gonna change another call came in things
are gonna change possibly this is Ryan
what up Ryan what the f baby what's up
some stuff that we might start seeing oh
yeah brother
and you sound fired up buddy boy you've
been having Red Bull or any or something
Oh word some news radio the other day
outdoor concerts and festivals things
like that they're starting to experiment
with like they want to slide you drones
over the top of the concert these drones
are gonna have like infrared sensors
that can tell if someone's hot and they
can see if someone's running hotter than
the rest of the concert goers so they're
gonna fly these drones up they're gonna
pick people out and then whatever the
security there is gonna go walk up to
them be like hey we got to pull you
outside take your temperature whatever
something like that Wow
yeah I could see it you out there
enjoying a little well in Elson you know
or a little uh you know Megan the
stallion or something or big Meg or
whatever
you know you out there Joe enjoying a
little bit of skinny Adele and next
thing you know they release a batch of
hot hunters just just they got they just
temperature drones just a bunch of damn
freakin Fahrenheit Falcons just nibbling
at you and you got one buddy he's hot
bro he's hot but he still wants to party
he's on a couple hits of acid you know
and he's you know he just he's deep deep
you know when he's listening to [ __ ]
he's at one concert but he's listening
to another concert only on headphones
you know he's at widespread panic but
he's listening to Michael Jackson on his
ear paws he's on two hits of acid and
he's running high on temperature and
body temp and he's he's he's saying hey
guys hide me hide me cover me cuz he
don't want one of them one of them
electronic temperature birds coming and
getting him and then the bouncers come
over the heat bouncers what's up man
are you hard bro it used to be you got
to be hot to get in the club now if
you're hot you got to get out the club
it's full circle a we need some ice-cold
[ __ ] man dude only cold [ __ ] only
I'm talking about real legitimate
[ __ ] from Norway Nordic Greenland
Iceland let me get that Antarctica
girl bring her to the club most she only
88 degrees man that she could stay in
hell she could be an investor she could
be a silent investor it's gonna be cold
people only at the club people will be
wearing ice around their neck real ice
diamonds and [ __ ] bro I need I need 14
degree gold do you have that that's what
I need it's gonna change
everything's gonna change is it though I
mean look do I really think it is I
really do not I really do not I think I
really think that we've taken a good
measure of trying to battle this virus I
think we've taken a really good measure
I also think it's time to get things
back going and there's some people like
life will never be the same you know
some people like men you will never
children will be born in incubator you
won't you won't even see your child till
he's seven you'll oh don't you you'll
never go on a date you're crazy
you'll never wash your own ass boy you
will never wash your own ass boy you
little freak
you little you little [ __ ] but that's
not true I think things gonna go back
very normal I really do I really really
do here's another call that came in uh
uh uh you guys have so many great ideas
man as always the hotline is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
you guys had so many interesting
interesting things that could happen you
know that could happen
homeward yo Co my name is Chris Jones
and from Des Moines what's up Chris
Jones and I used to know a fella named
Toby Jones or actually Chris Jones was
his name and they call him Toby and he
was real real white in his eyes his eyes
was always open pretty wide you know he
kind of had those eyes where you know he
would tell you he was going to sleep but
you didn't believe him you were like no
way and he had a real he was a young
fella that lived by me growing up and he
was kind of tough he was a rapscallion
and he wore kind of large shirts that
were collared and just a damn large
shirt
and sometime his shirt was so big he'd
go inside he'd be like look man I'll be
right back and he would just go inside
of his shirt or what where is he and he
come back out and have a licorice or
have a uh um a Jolly Rancher like damn
where the shirts come with a damn
kitchenette but they called him Toby and
he was a good friend when I was young
and he was a good kid and and I enjoyed
um I enjoyed living in the same
neighborhood as that boy Khanna all word
coma
it's kind of an experience um with this
whole coronavirus thing that I don't
think anyone's called in with yet or at
least I haven't heard it um so my uncle
passed away a couple weeks ago oh damn
man sorry to hear that brother and r.i.p
to his beautiful last brother and i'm
sure he was a good man brother and uh
you know it's it's an interesting
journey of life because you can die
that's the real caveat Oh word oh good
I'm not been out of shape about it
really too much or anything he was a
good dude at Stage four colon cancer and
he fought it for two and a half years
yeah oh man can you I mean I cannot even
fathom brother fighting something that
is you know fighting something that is
in your own ass that is um you know
that's like a level that's like that's
like a Zelda or that we'll never know
about I mean that is the ultimate Mortal
Kombat really it's fighting a curious
disease that is inside of your own ass
body ass ass you know I'm talking my
butt mm-hmm and I'm sorry to hear that
brother yeah my father passed away colon
cancer too and it's you know it's crazy
to think that something could be in your
acid
like you or that doesn't want you to be
alive onward you know my family was
mainly grateful for that and so he would
contains a city in Kansas City they're
still shut down they couldn't have more
than you know however many people in the
building for the funeral and he has five
kids and his wife and then the pastor
and the video Agra fer and all that
because they were putting the funeral on
YouTube so long story short my dad
didn't even get to go to the funeral
none of us were able to go to funeral
his kids were able to and his wife was
able to and everything we just watched
his funeral on YouTube just a couple
hours ago Wow
so they youtube and death you know the
Grim Reaper is is upgrading his
technology that's what it's come to
people the Grim Reaper is upgrading his
technology okay this man have to be
somewhere watching his uncle died on a
damn YouTube homeward and it was just it
was just kind of a trip it was just
really weird and I'm like the the
emotion wasn't really there watching
this funeral on YouTube and even for my
dad it was just it just wasn't quite the
same he even said something about it
just you know the human brain maybe
processing that kind of emotion
differently I don't know man just kind
of weird I'm very sorry to hear about
the the passing in your family and I'm
really sorry for your dad you know you
know I got to see my brother this
weekend in out there and so you tanned
it's you know it's a special gift to
have a brother and a man I bet that was
really tough for him but jeepers Jeepers
friend I when you hear this and you know
uh you know how are you gonna be on you
what
in the middle of a thing you know you
get an email reminder or a notification
of a damn tick-tock or something
and you you know they're sitting there
right there you know rent you know you
know Johnny was a good man and he he
survived today by and then it's like you
know what if somebody comments on the
thing Gang Gang first what if somebody
writes that on the freakin funeral you
know it just mmm yeah I mean that's just
a crazy you know somebody writes first
on your on your uncle's funeral or
somebody writes like oh I thought this
was magic and I thought they were gonna
cut the thing in half or something just
I mean in the way it's all it all could
get wild it all could get wild those are
some great some great suggestions man
some great thoughts about what to what
could happen what could the work of the
world be like you know I was over here I
was in springdale I was in Rockville and
I had a nice time
got to go fishing and I caught an
endangered animal fish I caught an
endangered animal fish and a thing a
little bastard he was he looked rare
right when I saw my said damn he looks
you know some fish look like they live
in the lake that they're in some fish
look like they just passing through like
they're from like a different place like
oh okay
and he had that vibe oh he this fellow
fellas an out-of-towner you know he
ain't a local boy he seemed like he had
read a few books you know like he had a
different vibe in him and it was a chub
it's called a North chub endangered Utah
and this fish
the Utah chub and the river I was in was
called the Virgin River and it is it's a
special River the Virgin River Utah let
me tell you about I want to tell you one
interesting fact about this waterway the
Virgin River chub federally listed
endangered specie eighteen-inch are rare
and beautiful it says here this fish is
the top native predator in the Virgin
River and I could I could have sensed
that a little it was daytime when I
caught it but I could see it getting
into some [ __ ] at night it had that look
about him the Virgin River chub feeds on
small fish insects and they like deep
pools with boulders and debris and I
caught one of those bastards boy and I
caught him on the liver I fish on
chicken liver and I fish on a worm
American worm and yeah I caught him man
so so that was nice we caught a couple
bull heads and my brother caught a
snapping turtle a big thing and and we
put everything back we put everything
back I want to let you know that today's
episode is uh is brought to you by recon
recon and you know we like to have
things personalized for us these days
you know some people that you like to
you know if I'm playing a game of um a
video game or something some I like to
be by myself I don't like to play in a
group I feel extra pressure or by brain
pressure body pressure but um but rake
on they offer a personalized experience
whether you're working from home or
working on your fitness
you want what you're listening to to be
what you are listening to you know some
people you if you're let's say if you
catch on a funeral you missed you can
catch it right there you know you can
catch it in and hear it as good as
possible and that's how ray con helps
you everyone needs a great pair of
wireless earbuds but before you go
dropping hundreds of dollars on a pair
you need to check out the wireless
earbuds from Ray Khan you already know
ray con earbuds started about half of
the price of any other wireless bud on
the market and and you got to think some
of these brands out there they don't
even earbuds aren't even their specialty
but they suddenly they just people buy
those but Ray Con they specialize in
sound their newest model the everyday
e25 earbuds are their best ones yet yet
with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass if you want
that boom in your head if you're
listening to a murder crime podcast and
you want to feel that you want to feel
that fellow sneaking up the the back
stairs with a tire iron you want to feel
that intensity they have a more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit ray cons wireless earbuds
are so comfortable they're perfect for
conference calls if you do group calls
or binging podcasts unlike some other
options
ray con earbuds are both stylish and
discreet there's no wires no stems
hanging out you're not gonna have
somebody come up and light the end of
your ear pod thinking it's a cigarette
some people think oh your ears doing um
doing a damn Camel light or camel crush
the company was co-founded by Ray J and
other celebrities now the time to get
the latest and greatest from Ray con get
15% off your order at buy rake on Bui RA
Y Co n comm slash Theo
that's bu why
our a YCO in.com slash t heo for 15% off
rake on wireless earbuds buy rake on
comm slash theo
go check it out and and support the pod
please this past weekend likes to
support small businesses and we want to
support lakeside maple lakeside maple
specializes in trail mix baked with pure
maple syrup sometimes you'll see a tree
and it'll look like it is just so happy
and so fun and joyous and usually that
tree has maple syrup in it
lakeside maple has three flavors
original spicy and ginger chai and my
favorite I believe is that ginger chai
all of their mixes are made by hand by
fans of this podcast did you know that
lakeside maple listens to this past
weekend it's a great snack if you're on
the go or in your car or a snack at work
or anything yeah you could be in a
gangbang and neither need to carb up a
little or just add a little bit to your
yogurt in the morning also get in there
and try out the best trail mix that
everyone thinks is granola but it's not
it's trail mix also try the new trail
mix butter a combination of almonds and
sunflower seeds baked with pure maple
syrup and fresh ground into the butter
Wow
go to lakeside maple dot-com and use
code th EO at checkout for 15% off
that's promo code th EO at checkout for
15% off lakeside
maple get that mix I'm gonna go buy some
I'm gonna send it to my mom and she
listens to this now so now she's gonna
expect it damn
let's get back to the show who is
listening that's who I like to know
got a couple listeners right here let's
uh let's catch him yo fizzle this is Joe
what up Joe from Philly Gang Gang
getting but though just calling in and
say yo man your cell was funny as hell
bro
all night long that work doing
overnights rate now you having like mine
my Bluetooth earphones in gang brother
and I appreciate you listen overnight
Freight as well also us a nickname for
burglary burglary and I like the way you
termina is it but uh and I don't
disrespect it I don't disrespect
criminal ISM if you're a businessman if
you out there just pocketing a little
lettuce or a little of that but if you
working at a job overnight and doing
overnight Freight or whatever I respect
that [ __ ] bro gang [ __ ]
another gentleman hey Co this is Logan
from Alberta Canada just wanted to let
you know we got listening way up here
and the great white north they get set
up here and up here in Canada I'm a
blacksmith and I and what a dichotomy a
blacksmith in the great white north and
that's about the most Canadian thing you
know it's so white there they gotta make
a black guy and that crazy they got a
you got a dude out there chiseling out
of black dude and in a shed you know
chiseling together a young a Darius or
you know chiseling together a UH a
sharkish actually a farrier so well that
is is I take raw steel and I build
horseshoes in a forge and an anvil
old-school style just like medieval days
build horseshoes and knives and stuff
and predominantly I build horseshoes and
nail them on horses feet they can go up
and go to work
oh I see what you're talking about um
yeah man I mean if that's what you want
to do then that's what's being done and
I think that's beautiful to be taking
care of a horse's foot because the rest
of us we see a horse we don't think
about that I see a horse I think I want
to put a couple of dollars on this one
striped passenger or whatever his name
is birdies uh diary
you know Johnson's pocket
I'll throw $200 on that thing you know
tricky rustle up throw $40.00 on tricky
Russell to come in third but you don't
think that there's somebody sees a horse
and says you know what boy about to
throw some shoes on that [ __ ] and um
and look I look I think that's beautiful
I would love to see you guys up the ante
though I'd love to see you put a little
whoa
put her on I'd love to see you guys put
put a Nike on on a little wolf I love to
see you throw a damn croc on a on a croc
now that would be some G [ __ ] I mean I
think it's savages held to be hammering
a piece of metal into a Clydesdale but
if it helps them then I think it's
beautiful
but I would love to see you put a damn
uh put a little piece of FUBU Footwear
on a frog now that would be crazy
I throw some a six on a on a on a some
I'd love to see an ASIC on a fox people
like damn that fox is fast as fox
because he he got a six thank you guys
thank you for supporting the podcast I
want to let you know that flowers are
blooming the grass is growing and it's
time to mow
your lawn I want to thank our sponsor
manscaped and this body they take care
of full body action hair you can trim
the hedges below the belt safely excuse
me
had a couple almonds you can trim the
hedges below the belt safely and
officially I'm talking about your balls
your scrotum screw manscaped is here to
make sure your balls are smooth and
smelling nice oh yeah
after all it's time for some spring
cleaning
may I that's the that's the calendar may
I help you clean your nuts huh sure
manscaped manscape is the only men's
brand dedicated to below the waist
grooming you know it I know it they have
forever changed the grooming game with
the new perfect package 3.0 kit it comes
with that lawn mower which is waterproof
now you can trim your wick over there in
the shower
make sure your root is all tightened up
you know I come from the an area
Louisiana and you don't like a man don't
like a you know when I was growing up it
was okay to have a little more hair
around your root and if you saw somebody
Wiener you barely saw it because they
had so much hair around it but now
everybody's taking their wiener and just
making it be fully visual and manscape
can help you do that people want to see
your wiener now it's crazy but it's true
inside the perfect package you'll also
find the manscaped crop preserver which
provides deodorant and moisturizer for
your body and for your balls for a
limited time subscribers get two free
gifts when you subscribe to the perfect
package you'll get a replacement blade
refill for your lawn mower delivered to
your door every three months make sure
your trimmer always stays hygienic and
clean the two free gifts you get the
shed travel bag and the patented high
performance
manscape boxer-briefs nice take care of
your package this is the perfect package
for your perfect package get 20% off and
free shipping
use the code theo th EO at manscaped
comm that's 20% off and free shipping
with the code theo at manscaped comm
that's 20% off with Free Shipping at
manscape calm and use code th e oh it's
spring cleaning baby and your balls will
thank you
you know I remember when I was when I
was a child for one for one year I went
to a school and it was called Lyon
Elementary and they misspelled it ly o N
and named after this guy Donald Lyon and
he was the first man actually in our
town that had ever seen I guess a that
had ever seen a Louisiana black bear and
he didn't have one or anything but he
had seen it and no one else had seen it
and there used to be value back then to
seeing something before you could just
have a camera or something you had to
see it and tell people you could maybe
draw him a picture or make them a thing
out of clay oh here it is
this is what it is you know it's a bits
of bear like well then it looks like a
fat goat well well I'm not that good of
a sculptor but that doesn't mean I
didn't see it and I went to that school
man it was a kind of a it was a school
that was a little closer to where I grew
up and it was it was its specialized in
special education and these are a lot of
children who were mental you know
mentally unique rare a lot of kids kind
of seemed like they're good they want to
do magic or something but they're just
children and they don't and they just
you know sometimes they be in remedial
classes you'll see a kid four years in
the second grade but all of them are
happy about it and they loved it and and
it was good man and I
went because it was close to us and I
enjoyed it and the principal was this
man Troy or T Roy Jackson and he could
whistle dude this guy God he could
whistle my god he could just pass wind
through his lips boy he could just
whistle man imagine something flying out
of your lips through a really small hole
now imagine that thing is beautiful
that's whistling and and and he could do
it and he could do it man he could
whistle before he could whistle from one
end of the property to the other you
could hear him at the other end of the
property and which is one of the reasons
one of the reasons why I even got the
job and a net man could god he could
whistle and sometimes you know uh you
know sometimes I still think about him
and I think he passed away he might have
died um all right let's get into a
couple more calls here here we go
you'll see oh I'm in a conundrum
onion onion ooh that is a tough young
man that is a tubby you know because you
know it onion onion is the real deal now
onion is the real onion comes with all
the emotions you know it's probably the
national vegetable of this past weekend
listeners you know this is the kind of
podcast I'm you got to crack into that
onion onion is it's just that you know
it's the one that went to school and it
got its you know it's it's had some
tough times and maybe it went through a
bad marriage or two and then fun
his [ __ ] onions that have just that
is gooped out they gooped out on
methamphetamine sir you know it had been
smoking doing cigarettes and doing a
little bit of um you know sneaking a
little sip of fireball you know at
church or something that's a tough one
man onions are Funyuns
but Funyuns got that fun in them you
know they go on a community college you
know and they had it they worked at
Subway for a couple months before some
[ __ ] went up [ __ ] went down and some
money went missing but onions onions you
know they grow in a real guard and then
they no other vegetables you know they
might have a carrot in their phone they
might have a you know a way to get in
touch with a rhubarb or something or in
a rolodex at their house you know what
onion has a chance to be part of other
recipes on onion onion you might see
onion in a sign and a salad or salad or
salad actually not said a lot you might
see an onion in a salad
you know you might see a onion in it on
on the edge of a state Kerr buy Funyuns
nobody's ever starving a damn steak and
Funyuns a Funyuns ain't coming on a
burger so I'm staying real with it man
real with the rock with that I'm going
to onions I'm going onions on that one
thank you for for checking in about that
as well we got this call that came in
thank you for calling down there in
Baton Rouge you know spent much much of
time down there and I bought some
cocaine down there once and and went
jogging on it and that's called run
running the gram baby gang homework
I got a who do you think would win in a
feud between Hillary Clinton and Carol
Bastion got a better hit man and all
so they both kind of look alike don't
they they they do have a similar visual
when I get that visual um they look a
little similar who would win on a
Hillary and Carol Baskin well you know
Hillary's gonna have a lot more
firepower she's gonna have men in suits
doing her business she's gonna have a
lot more she's gonna have workers
carrying it out Carol's gonna bait you
with that Kitty and then snuff yeah you
know Carol's gonna do that you know
flowered headdress let's go skip through
the garden and then damn hit you with
that sharp rake that's a tough one I
mean Hillary just has so much there's so
much you know Hillary's gonna be harder
to get to Carol's gonna be probably kind
of easy access she's on YouTube but
Hillary you might be able to bait
Hillary more with with something I don't
know it'd be vicious I'd love to watch
him wrestle man I would love to watch
them wrestle that's a good one man
that's a toss-up for me that is a
toss-up for me what else is goin on man
oh I'll tell you I was gonna tell you
when I was at that school so I'm at that
lion elementary and this was a secondary
the premier Elementary School in our
town was Covington elementary and Lyons
elementary was it was secondary and it
was just uh it was a type of place it
was you know it was just it was a second
it was a you know it was the Bad News
Bears of education it was you know we
didn't have some of the books people had
just written them some of the school
books somebody's daddy had read
like DZ's mr. Hoffa this is wrong you
know that the kickball it was just a
volleyball and somebody wrote kick on it
with a marker or marks a lot you know
the windows the windows have been like
repurposed from a local prison so they a
lot of them was that you know you
couldn't see through them it was just
mirror sided you know and uh and you'd
have people that carve crazy stuff into
him you know I didn't do it you know
God shall be my last decider just you
know prison prison chatter it was just a
secondary elementary and they had this
boy there this kid Wyatt power was his
name and now I really mean it Hunt's
like that's that's a wild name to have
dude you know Wyatt power but at the
time I don't it wasn't anything racial
it was probably a it's probably like the
family name cuz I think he was Wyatt
you know Wyatt power the sixth or
whatever um and he was always he always
had him had a little cricket on him or a
little salamander you know he always had
a had a little snail or something or a
little little half a handful of
lightning bugs day timers making him
work the daytime shift and that [ __ ]
hurt me
this should hurt my feelings man when
you see a lightning bug working in the
daytime you can't shake that once you've
seen it but I remember it was showing
telling he told everybody in class or
that he was gonna get a cricket right to
pass gas right cuz remember when you
were a child this was third grade so
passing gas or farting or doing body
fart was about the most it was like
though it was coming band for kids it's
the only instrument really you have two
instruments your mouth when you do your
underarms like that and the
your mud so he would do farts body farts
he said he could get a cricket to do one
so we're all like saying FFF or whatever
kids say you know not F but whatever
means f fu Y it all of this and that BS
in him telling him to go BS himself well
here's what how curd so the day he was
supposed to do it I remember seeing him
at recess and he was just pacing around
and just scared and he was on these
shitty monkey bars we had and we did I
mean a monkey did if a monkey saw these
monkey bars he would just he would not
even go by him you know they were more
for a swan or some you might see a
sparrow on them they just everything at
this school was just rot good and so I
could tell he was nervous I could tell
he was scared right and because I'm like
he this he can't do this he can't do
this you know a man can't get a um
little cricket to do a fart you know it
can't he can't do it
so anyway next thing I know they were
back in class and he had I guess gotten
some flour right and we're all sitting
there watching and the teacher let him
do it you know they were like just right
before class started they were gonna
give him like two minutes to you know it
was a bit of a showman so I remember and
this happened really fast but he like
threw the flower into words we're all
sitting there in like a semicircle
he threw like threw the flower and
everyone's face and then while we were
all kind of what I guess he thought was
going to be blinded by the flower he
turned around and he basically ended up
defecating onto the floor of the
classroom but I think what he admit to
do was pass gas do fart I think he had
meant to do fart but he you know he was
he was gonna blind us with the flower
and then make a do a fart a body fart
and then have us believe that this that
the cricket had done it because there
was a cricket sorry
there was a cricket there and instead
man everybody had flour in the next
thing you know I just remember it really
smelled like poop and then somebody said
oh Wyatt pooped on the floor and it was
just you know it just got you just it's
hard to pull off magic is really it's
hard to pull off magic if you're doing
it all alone
but anyway man what else do we have
let's get into a little bit more so we
can get get on with our day man thank
you guys for all the all the
communication and thanks for carrying
out the podcast was late you know I was
just I was just enjoying myself you know
I was really just enjoying myself
we got a patreon question that came in
and this from Kim chicken's camping is
fun beautiful country out here how do
you like getting being back inside do
you have a balcony you can sit on to
enjoy nature I have a park near me so I
go over there but yeah it was really
nice you know I went and stayed at a
campground so you know um I I wouldn't
stayed at a campground I went with my
friend and and it was it was nice we
stayed at a campground one night stayed
by my family's in-laws the other night
my brother and his wife were there with
their children and yeah just you know
you you hook the water in at a camper
and just did it all you know you got to
take out the gray water take out the
dark water um you know plugging him for
electricity running the generator we
didn't even use a generator said I was
nice it was nice and cool and if you've
never driven through Zion National Park
the park wasn't open but you could drive
through it you can motor owned and
hot-diggity it was beautiful and I like
B you know you go to a campground I got
somebody next door they set up they they
bring their whole life out there they
slanging they got a strawberry garden
some people go camp at these campgrounds
for a year they'll do a 6-month lease
you park that thing plug in the
electricity $50 a night beautiful great
way to spend that stimulus check
speaking of stimulus check here's a call
that came in
what's up Cooper thank you for calling
brother homeward and you know you're
talking about being grateful for the
1200 and everything and our government
is really helping us out and listen if
you're struggling and you needed that
1200 then I'm definitely glad you got it
but when you really look at it man
and all the money they spent and printed
for the stimulus it was about six
trillion dollars so you know they that's
more than $15,000 per person
most of that's gone to you know
wealthier people it's going all back to
the top you know and the reality is
that's our money in the first place
they're just going into debt robbing
future generations the government
doesn't produce any money itself so it's
nice that people are getting a couple
crumbs but number one is their money in
the first place and number two
everybody's going into debt and
additional almost $20,000 just to get a
little balance so thank you man I
appreciate it yeah you know I don't know
it's I don't know a ton exactly how it
works you know I do know that if we just
print money that it lowers the overall
value of money because there's more some
people are just like just give me money
get me a get me some money man print
money mud you see people out there like
why can't the government doesn't give me
for $60 why can't you just give me $60
smile
well I mean they can but it's just like
in the end the value the overall value
of it goes down because if we just print
more of it
[Music]
yeah it's look at those yeah there's
definitely a lot more into it I think my
overall my point I felt like was just
that and I think you're saying it as
well that that yeah like we get to it's
nice on the surface if it looks this way
but that there's bigger things in the
background going on that are affecting
us more long-term and yeah I agree I
agree man that there's a lot happening
but I guess yeah it's just it's even if
the money that we're making ends up
lowering the value of our money down the
road if it you know yeah it might not be
the best long-term move but yeah at
least we're just Senate we're in a
whether it's good or not it is
interesting that we have and it makes us
feel good that we have a structure here
in the US where they can kind of where
at least people are able to be helped
you know I feel like we do help
sometimes the lowest common denominator
people that don't want to contribute I
wish there was a way to to see if people
are contributing to society you know I
wish there was an evaluation or a score
in a way but it would have to encompass
so many things you would have to
encompass you know their ability based
on their circumstances based on their
opportunity you would have to encompass
all those things but yeah just you get
so many opportunities in America you
know if you you know if you if you lose
your home you can get up of you you know
you can get a mortgage you can get a
second mortgage you can get it you can
lose your home you can get a mobile home
you could be homeless and still get a
money from the government
you know there's shelters we just did
there's so much there's so many there's
such a structure in place to to help us
now how long how long can we keep it
going
I don't know or at least the facade of
it going I don't know it's really
interesting man it's a bigger
conversation but here I'll hear let's
hear a little bit more on what you have
to say Matt you know you got to take a
little bit of a deeper look at it
sometimes you can't just take everything
off face value and you know we do live
in a great country and we live in a
great society and you know it
you can't give all that credit to the
government though you know it that it's
just not the case
it's you know the free market is the
people technology that's allowed us to
live such comfortable lives it ain't the
goddamn government man so yeah man you
know is that he Bravo would say look
into it yeah good call man yeah look
into it yeah it's interesting with the
virus like that's why a lot of people
they want they want to be able to open
their businesses back up they want to be
able to they want to be able to go live
normal lives again and if we lived in a
if we live in a communist country or
socially then they the government could
say okay shut down you have to do it
that's it
well we don't live in that we live in
you know a democracy where people can
have businesses and at a certain point
it like the people want their rights
they want to be able to run their
businesses so it's really interesting
you know it's a real experiment and I
understand why people now are like let's
get back let's let's take some chances
at getting it back to normal you know
other people like you want to kill every
we want to kill everybody
you're gonna kill everybody well I mean
some people could stay home I mean you
know it's that's the thing about America
it's like everybody everybody has a say
you know when the government isn't too
the bee isn't the be-all-end-all and and
and the people have a voice or at least
we think that we do you know it's
interesting man it's a lot of
interesting levels of stuff going on I
personally I felt like when I was in I
mean I was just in southern Utah but I
felt like I went to some I went to just
a whole new world but I was able to go
to restaurants there's one horrible
place I want to call Porter's I think it
was Jesus Christ
why would you sell food to somebody if
your food isn't any good you're wasting
your time your work you're wasting their
time hey hey this is garbage you want
some huh you're gonna hate it and I
don't even like I don't even like it I
work here I don't even like it so nobody
cares along the entire transaction line
anyway let's take another call or two
that came in and here we go hey you know
this agent calling from down here in
Oklahoma what's up Adrian thank you for
calling young fellah gang [ __ ] I'm
sitting here listening to your latest
latest episode and the guy where he went
to college for nine years and this not
know and that's badass that he graduated
finally kind of had a similar story you
know growing up wrestling you know
throughout school got a college
scholarships for wrestling turns out
ended up getting my girlfriend pregnant
oh yeah boy wrestling with that ass you
feel me wrestling with them are varese
baby gang wife now you know we've been
together for 13 years but uh have you
put some of my stuff my some of my
dreams on hold you know but come this
December I'll be graduating and working
on power lines out here you know gang
[ __ ] keep doing you man I really enjoy
it Gang Gang buzz but man look I like to
call man uh you know you got a you
always have to work we got to stay
working and you know you know you say
you had to put your dreams on hold
and I could understand that it's got to
be really tough you know I've always had
the dreams also of having a family and
of and of being able to be in that
comfortable situation and you know
having that place to go home to in the
evening and you know you open your door
and you know there's somebody there that
cares about you and that you care about
and uh and and you maintain that you
know you you know you wake up each day
and go to bed each night knowing that
you know this is my family and you know
I'm not straying from this plan and this
is what I'm here to do and it's funny
because to me that's almost a dream you
know telling jokes and screwing around
basically or whatever I do I don't know
but that kind of stuff was always the
easier part for me when I think of
walking into a home and you know having
there be someone that I love and you
know and I want to touch them and be
naughty and everything and they got a
child or something any other room may be
doing a you know one of those color by
numbers or doing a you know drawing some
[ __ ] or something but you know just
having that that place having that
continuity
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of power in that that's a real dream and
um I think you know you'll get other
chances for your for your you know you
got to wrestle you'll get other chances
to wrestle bra hell you up there
wrestling with voltage daddy did you
have their wrestling with them gigawatts
David that frickin that frickin uh I'd
hate to see one of those strong cables
put you in a damn leg lock son that
should it be lights out
dude that thing will blow your occipital
right out of your eye yes but
congratulations man nine years in school
you got it you got your family and look
now they got all these older leagues you
could always get into a 40 or older
wrestling you know I mean I still want
to go and train some jiu-jitsu I still
want to get out there onto the mats you
know but but yeah you know we all have
dreams and some of them we get to do now
and some of them we get to do later man
but it sounds like you're making some
things come true in your life and also
in the lives of others man so I see you
I see what you're doing bro you know and
be safe up there dog to hang you up
there on them power lines boy violin you
wildin bro good luck dude I don't want
don't make me go to a damn YouTube
funeral don't make me comment buzz buzz
because of the power that would be the
first thing I would come in
all right let's solisten let's get
through let's get through this this
wonderful episode and we got another
call text came in from patreon Aaron
Lugo do you see any beautiful stars out
in southern Utah I did see some stars I
did see some nice stars out there what
did I see man the mountains are just it
it it was the most beautiful place I've
seen in America I mean it really was it
just so majestic it just
I mean we went out to gooseberry point
we went up to Katy all we found snow for
the kiddos and you know nephews got to
throw snow
I met a kid out there who had a mullet
just like me a little fella named Colton
or something or Colby or something I
think named after the cheese and just a
beautiful just group out there my little
nephew was weird bro he put in front of
his paint like his wet part of his
crotch and like a front part of his
pants in the water just cooling off his
junk just kids are weird in my hand kids
are weird and they're wonderful but
they're in there but they're also weird
but you had a nice time and I was lucky
to be able to go do that and and it was
a little risky at first but look I think
we're gonna smoothly get back into
regular life and I'm looking forward to
it that's really what I think and I hope
everybody is adjusting and getting ready
to adjust comfortably and I hope that
people have found some good some joy and
some good things have happened to them
during this time let's take a call here
we go
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three Tanner from Nebraska
whatup Tanner and um from Nebraska baby
and this is my third time calling the
first time I added is Ola short in
second time I got in arrested by a
workaholic so I just wanted to say that
that my car got broken into and I lost
all my tools that I need for school
because I'm going to be an electrician
I'm on the last quarter to be on
electrical technology associate degree
so I just wanted to tell everybody to be
safe and keep your tools locked up and
don't leave prescription glasses because
they'll take those twos they'll take
everything the aux cord and even my
Cologne so mmm there must be a market
out there Sinatra used Cologne but well
I used to you know my mother would for a
little while was in the secondary magnet
market you know people throw magnets
away and they don't want to
anymore frigerator magnets and that kind
of [ __ ] and for a while there in the in
the 90s there was a secondary market
there for magnet's magnetic don't work
there left my car lacks so that's good I
just want to say thanks for anything you
do
stay safe lock your cars like a house
dan dan glows blue gang man I'm sorry to
hear about your tools man that really
who would take your tools dude you got
to finish up school mailing me let me
see if I can hit your hotline here dawg
Tanner got them hitters hey man this is
Theo von bro can you hear me hey how's
it going man I got your call about the
tools man what happened man dude it's
cool man
well congratulations you're almost being
done with the degree I wanted to see if
maybe we couldn't help out by if there's
tools that you still need to replace
them and we'd love to replace them for
you
oh yeah I mean that could be honest I
mean honestly I tried to I tried to tell
everyone like this is just like a
horrible thing that happened that I mean
it does happen and I mean I've done in a
pretty great position with my family was
kind of taken care of me and it's it's
really remarkable other people have
reached out and asked me if I needed to
or saw me I mean there are some stuff
that would be nice to get but I don't
wanna force you guys oh no
well it's no man I like your attitude
brother yeah we'd love to
we'll have Nick reach out and see if
there's a couple of things that we can't
help out with or you know things that
you need to you know that that that you
still need and whatever it is and we
want to help out dude um you know I
think it's cool to get a trade you know
and especially you know you they're so
close to the finish line and and I hate
it when that kind of stuff happens man
make sure you don't lose your face in
humanity because not all people are like
that and that kind of hit home for me
and I mean I mean not all people are
like that so yeah yeah that's true man I
love that lesson bro
I'm glad you just said that man it's it
is it's because it's so easy that we
could just say Oh everything's like that
it's so easy to just jump on that it's a
little harder to to keep our own head up
and and to kind of hold the line and say
you know what there's that's just one
thing that happened it's unfortunate but
that's not everybody like that then I
mean think of all the times that it
hasn't happened to you how many times
have you gone just somewhere safely and
you haven't even thought about wow I
didn't die today my kids it's easy to
focus on the negatives but it's hard to
like focus on the positives so that's
fine
messaging that's what I've learned over
this last weekend just kind of working
through it and just protecting myself
and my families just recognize when you
do have something good so yeah yeah I
love it man I love your attitude man I'm
gonna have Nick reach out and keep in
touch and if there's things that we can
help help you replace or anything you
you know that you need to help you get
through to the end of the semester and
we want to help out well that's nice you
just say man and best of luck to with
this last semester all right peace ander
man have a good day brother all right
gang for a piece man that's nice you
know that's nice to be reminded oh it's
nice to be reminded that you know we can
look at you know we can look at the we
can look at all the rocks or we could
ride in the river man yeah just for that
hit that really hit me at is to focus on
the good brah it's a lot of good out
there a lot of fun stuff going on a lot
of people having fun we'll take this one
this last call that came in this is kind
of wild but I wanted to hear it hey
what's up Salamun Texas I wanted to tell
you that up I rear-ended your car
when I on my 18th birthday in Covington
Louisiana and you got out and I was like
oh my god it's my birthday and I just
crashed the car then I had force focus
and you had a mapping of Camry saloon
and you said uh your birthday said yeah
so it's all right make it out of here
you let me go never forget that [ __ ]
game
and that's funny man that's funny
well I'm glad I'm glad that it worked
out that over that way Tyler man uh I
probably it probably did I remember I
would borrow a Camry sometimes and I
wasn't supposed to be doing and I would
vote you know I would dip chewing
tobacco real heavy that plugged tobacco
and I vomit out of the windows of it so
who knows man I could have been not in a
car that I was supposed to be in but I'm
glad we both made it out unscathed from
that thank you guys man thanks for
making this this episode was fun this is
fun just hearing getting getting
people's different points of views and
and just I don't know just being alive
you know this fun there's this is it
this is the gift and and a lot of the
gift is each other and a lot of the gift
is the experiences that we have and
sharing them and I'm not trying to
preach that I'm just I believe that you
know I believe that and I believe that
right now after this episode you know
this this just made me feel it was fun
you know [ __ ] I got a guy hero who we
got in a car accident you know we got
some blacksmith we got a guy making
black people in Canada I mean if that
isn't as beautiful you know if that
isn't trying to help another race I
don't know what it is man it's just
there's a lot going on brother there's a
lot going on let's say well I'll take
one more let's go apo Tate from Des
Moines I'm just calling in I listened to
that ladies night and then it touched my
soul and in a lot of ways you know are
you talking about lights and what's
going on in these current times I just
wanted to call in man I've been
listening for a while now and you do
help people man you really do and I'm
sure you know it I'm sure you get told
it every day but I mean I struggle with
some of the same problems that you do
man
not not being able to lead myself you
know that addiction piece and at
depression piece man it's this legit
I've been struggling with that for a
couple years now you know it's a it's a
daily battle and you know it like I know
it like everyone that struggles with it
knows it but I did just get a new dog
and I named them Theo that's but it's
pretty cool man
he held me a lot and take care of man
look love you love you too bro thanks
man thanks for the nice message dude if
that dog starts doing cocaine boy you
know it you know that's then we are of
the same breed for sure but nah man you
know you do the same thing for me man by
making that call and it is a daily
battle you know a lot of people that
struggle with addiction and that sort of
thing man when when you have a brain
like us as I don't think other people
realize this my problem everyday isn't
not drinking or doing drugs my problem
is me and just something inside of me
that doesn't fit correctly and that
every day I have to get up and have to
sand it and I have to make sure that
it's gonna it's like I have this puzzle
piece that regrows overnight and it can
regrow negatively overnight and I got to
get up in the morning and I got to
evaluate what's going on before I can
attach myself to the rest of the world
or things ain't gonna be real kosher but
thank you for that bro thank you for the
nice message man a lot of good people
around these parts bro let's roll out
the same way we came in Maine I know
some of y'all like to get bent out and
so a good song to do it too is uh is
this some right here man drunk outdoors
you guys take care of yourselves me and
be good to yourself you know I'm gonna
try to do the same all right yeah
[Music]
when the Shah
get out dog
[Music]
down on the corner
cookie went gasps I'm not from
[Music]
you got money you've got money get that
hitter
[Music]
not to roll right in the tape in an
episode of a king in a sting here so
there's been a great prep for that man
has put me in put me in a comfortable
place mine and thank you to the North
Mississippi Allstars and this song drunk
outdoors we'll put a link read and get
that hitter man in the youtubes
[Music]
dance